there are countless ways for esports
competitors to immortalize themselves
through self-expression whether it's in
the form of awe-inspiring no-scopes
what
[Music]
[Applause]
night it can be an expertly executed
outplay caps looking for a kill on to
fake okay
let's see where the faker finds the
right spot he doesn't he's gonna flash
but perhaps the most visceral form of
self-expression in all of esports
actually comes
after the play
i'm talking of course
about the pop-off
what is going on through that oh
[Applause]
now on the surface a pop-off might look
like just a celebration and sometimes
that's really all it is but the
beautiful thing about these ecstatic yet
occasionally awkward acts is that they
can be so much more they can lay the
foundation for infamous rivalries they
can become part of community folklore or
they can be used to make resounding
statements use it well oh
three and that's gonna do it buffalo
taking out scar with the pop off
pop-offs can also be elaborately planned
performances or off-the-cuff emotional
releases they can add exclamation points
to emphatic victories and in some cases
become bigger than the victories
themselves tell him about himself talk
to him tell him about himself tell him
about himself but when it comes to these
occasionally over the top acts of raw
unfiltered jubilation perhaps no single
esport boasts a catalog thicker
than melee no but wait a minute
he's taking his shirt off
he's searching the crowd
destruction
[Applause]
and chief among melee's pantheon of
pop-off perfectors has to be none other
than juan hungrybox de bienna the
puff-playing grub-loving mad lad who has
built a reputation for losing himself in
the moment
hbox's pop-offs are legendary they're
often hilarious and some of them have
become iconically inspirational but
they're also not without their
controversy so how did hungrybox's
unrestrainable passion for the game add
to his reputation as melee's most
divisive god how have his animated acts
ascended to meme status
and more importantly
is he taking his animated antics
a little too far
yeah mother
[Music]
okay so before we dive into the video i
must ask that you please like subscribe
and turn on notifications if you are one
of those die hards out there who really
wants us to do more melee content this
is how you let us know okay so for those
who are not well acquainted with
hungrybox here's a quick rundown he
started playing melee competitively back
in 2007. and eventually became a
competitor and content creator for team
liquid fast forward to 2016 and
hungrybox decides to quit his job as a
chemical engineer to pursue his dream of
becoming a professional party game
player what the hell were you thinking
all jokes aside taking a massive chance
on melee turned out to be the right call
for hbox over the course of his
illustrious career hbox has cemented his
place among the game's five fabled gods
by being
inhumanly good at the game everyone
wants that money that's schmutty
baby
oh oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
now that's not to say that hbox is all
work and no play despite being a fierce
competitor he's always been charismatic
down to earth and effortlessly
entertaining every smasher dropped into
an arena hunger games style
battle royale style whatever you want to
call it who is walking out victorious me
you yeah why are you if it's enough
space if i have enough space i can do
anything
what are you talking about
[Laughter]
anyway today we are not here to focus on
hbox's rise as melee's most recognizable
puff player for that you can check out
our story of hungrybox instead we are
gonna focus on the one characteristic
that's sort of come to define hungrybox
over the course of his career
for better
and for worse
and that
is his passion since day one hbox has
been in love with competing and he has
never shied away from showing everyone
just how much winning means to him both
both states we'll be back here rest rest
it's over oh my goodness with his hands
on his head
it's over pop
off coming in way high
coming in way higher just like that
[Applause]
and as hbox continued to enjoy
competitive success his reactions to
victory only became more frequent and
more bombastic although at times they
could be interpreted as being just
a little bit bm oh my goodness
oh he wanted a little tool
and this could be
the best man in hungrybox he moves on
oh my
god is still
here in the bracket in those early days
whether he intended it or not hbox was
becoming a divisive figure in the melee
scene he was accused of refusing to play
friendlies with other pro players and
conducting himself in a way that drew
questions about his character but
instead of pleading his innocence or
trying to make amends with the community
hbox decided to really lean into his
heel like personal
i don't know if you can hear this in my
headset but like listen to the crowd the
crowd is not happy
[Applause]
everybody says what are you gonna do
now the truth is as much as being the
guy everybody loved to hate did take its
toll on juan between 2016 and 2018 he
was able to use the community's ire
towards him as motivation leading him to
win countless events but it was after
his grand final showdown at evo 2016
with his long time rival armada that
things between hbox and the scene began
to change
hbox was at the top of the melee
mountain and with the other four gods
retiring or just slowing down he found
himself becoming more or less the face
of competitive melee over the next
couple of years but with the weight of
that new responsibility resting firmly
on his shoulders he realized he needed
to change i think hungrybox
was a guy who was way too fat way too
into his own ego and
it was a kid who wanted attention
finally got it and then
this was an idiot with it there's a
beauty in not always being
the center of attention there's a beauty
in
watching other people succeed
watching your friends do well seeing
more people have to invest yourself
now as much as self-awareness and
development is something that everybody
can get behind
in hungrybox's case
not everyone was convinced in fact even
among his peers there were those who
didn't really think that he was worth
giving a second chance this is going to
sound very harsh and i don't want this i
don't want to make the video about him
so obviously i have had you know
an interesting
not cordial relationship with hungrybox
i have been pretty upfront about the
fact that i hate him as a person even
though hbox tried to present a more
humble and mature version of himself
some members of the melee community just
couldn't get past well the past but that
all came to a head
with crab gate
just comes down aggressively
oh
there
hbox is your pound 2019
smash bros melee champion
what a run from him to come all the way
back from losers and take that of course
gotta give it up for mango the three-o
shades of the mango of old but hungrybox
what is the champion what is that once
again what is that what is it i'm not
sure what that is
through this
who threw this at me
[Music]
you know how hard i work on here
yes that is right the one time that hbox
decided not to pop off on stage
somebody hurled a literal dead
crustacean at him now looking back the
situation was kind of hilarious in a
purely absurdist sense but the truth is
that it really was not
cool to the point where it forced the
smash community to acknowledge that
their hatred for hbox had simply gone
too far they finally began to accept the
fact that in spite of his exceptional
talent he really was
just like them a passionate melee super
fan who had devoted his life to the game
and it was time to show him some love
which is exactly what they did
now with the attitude of the community
shifting in his favor the appreciation
for his pop-offs also began to grow what
were once seen as over-exaggerated acts
of faux alpha behavior were now looked
back upon and revered for their at times
hilarious intensity and their
expectation-defying creativity but that
is not to say that on occasion hbox
hasn't gone a little too far with his
emotional outbursts
in fact there have been times where they
have come at the expense of his own
well-being
oh my god he's going to break the tv
the pop off other than sin to win
pop off box he's back you know what this
to be honest
i understand why right now yeah i mean
he's like he was holding it okay dude
after the fact of the tournament i go to
the doctors i had burst
like three or four
blood vessels inside my foot hell even
coveted shutting down lands didn't stop
him from celebrating winds in his
bedroom
like it was a smelly overcrowded
convention center come on you know
you're [ __ ] with [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hbox's pop-offs were no longer just
spectacle they had ascended into melee
meme
it even got to the point where people
were reviewing them and creating their
own tier lists
[Music]
oh my god he [ __ ] lost it i i think
it's eightier but that's a good that's
that's a high atr that is a funny one
hell one talented smasher even remixed
one of them
[Music]
but beyond the incredible clips and
memorable memes they've inspired what
really stands out about hbox's
insane pop-offs
is what they say about his enduring
competitive spirit for a guy who's
played the game since basically its
beginning and has won literally
everything there is to win hbox still
gets the same feeling taking a set today
that he did all those years ago
and hungrybox
takes it toss the chair get out of here
for most esports pros who've
accomplished all of their competitive
dreams it's kind of hard to stay
motivated especially when you've been at
the top of your game for so long which
is why so many of them end up pursuing
new outlets to develop their talents and
honestly no one would hold it against
juan for doing just that but despite
being an enduring vestige of melee's
glorious past a successful content
creator lending his expertise to
broadcasts running his own events and
now partially owning team liquid
hungrybox is still well hungry to be the
best and that's one of those things that
you just
can't fake
i hate
hate when people say it's acting like
i just literally put
every ounce of my existence into every
match that i do
so
unsurprisingly when i win a close
situation my emotion and my relief is
released in a very cathartic way at the
end of the day hbox's fire to be the
best is both the source of his success
and the drama that's followed him
throughout his career it continues to
see him routinely secure top eight
finishes against the next generation of
smashers and honestly
it doesn't look like that flame will be
going out anytime soon
remember my name
i actually have a great clip from
like last week i was playing a ranked
game
and i clutched with like
literally three seconds left
i clutched on a on a juke like a really
clean juke
in siege
and uh and i
i just popped off like it was like i was
so i was like feeling it dude like yeah
i'm so much [ __ ] better like i just
went like crazy